le 21 décembre j'étudie diagnostic et du
lymphome de hodgkin
sa peau était une nouvelle facile à
digérer
c'est une onde de choc dans le monde du
snowboard maxence parrot médaillé
d'argent des jeux de cannes chain en
2018 doit mettre les résultats sportifs
de côté et ne penser qu'à lui
ma première réaction a été de me dire
est-ce qu'on peut pousser le traitement
au moins après les x games que j'ai
confectionné les premiers symptômes sont
apparus à l'automne des démangeaisons et
aussi une bosse dans le cou qui a mené à
une biopsie
il s'agit du même type de cancer qui a
vaincu le joueur de hockey mario lemieux
il avait reçu le diagnostic en 1993
quand il avait 27 ans maxence parrot a
reçu une première séance de
chimiothérapie la semaine dernière des
traitements qui lui sont familiers
puisque son meilleur ami jean david
lessard aujourd'hui en rémission a eu le
même cancer avant les jeux de
pyeongchang l'an dernier les deux amis
s'étaient promis que l'un gagnera une
médaille et l'autre vaincre la maladie
c'est à mon tour de combattre j'ai la
chance de voir le parcours que fait il
me soutient là dedans
chaque jour à 24 ans maxence parrot a
déjà marqué l'histoire de son sport par
l'exécution de saut que personne ne
croyait possible par exemple il a été le
premier à réussir un switch quadruples
en 2014 il est devenu le second
planchistes a remporté les épreuves de
slopestyle et de big air aux mêmes x
games
si maxence parrot évoque la peur en
parlant du cancer son préparateur mental
et lui optimiste
ça prend quand même force puisque le jkc
particulière pour air pour pouvoir
exécuter ce week end après week end fait
comme moi c'est extrêmement confiants
que les habiletés mentales pour
combattre au grand soulagement de
l'athlète
les médecins l'encouragent à rester
actif pendant son traitement qui prendra
fin en juin
maxence parrot entend être de retour sur
sa planche dès la saison prochaine
marie match aulas radio canada montréal